Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast from Monday,
August 20th, 2007 18.
Sorry. What's going on?
How are you?
How was your weekend?
Did you or did you not enjoy yourself?
Did you or did you dad abused
substances that were a,
a legal and, and uh, possibly. Dot. Um,
I was actually out in Las Vegas,
hot as Fuck Las Vegas.
Let's make it fun.
And everybody talking about how can
you believe how hot it is out here?
It's like, yeah man, we're in
a fucking desert in August.
I can completely understand why
it is so fucking hot out here.
Um, and then you get the global
warming thing going on, you know, with,
have to have to for half the world's
on fire according to the news.
Um, yeah, I can, I can see why it'd
be a little small to read their, um,
you know,
what's so fucked up about Las Vegas is
I was thinking when I was out there,
it's like there's,
there's only one reason and one reason
only that that place exists and that is
air conditioning.
Okay.
I know back in the day, you
know, when they had like
three or four little fucking,
I dunno, one floor casinos
in the middle of nowhere.
Whatever the hell was going on out
there. I did. I forget the whole story.
All right. I've watched all the
goddamn movies. I saw casino,
I saw a fucking Bugsy goes
to fucking pebble beach,
whatever the fuck it was
called. I watched that one. I,
I don't remember what the fuck. I'm
sure there was some fans, you know,
overhead fans. Is that all they had back
in the day? But I can tell you right now,
nobody fucking went out there in August.
Well, maybe they did. I don't know.
But I'm just, anyways, it's
a different breed of people.
That was the greatest generation
back then. Okay. They, they, they,
they defeated Adolf Hitler,
defeated Japan,
you know, date, date, day, beat their
wives, and then nothing was said about it.
You know, they will all those women back
there, Rosie the riveter, what happened,
ah, was a rebut. I walked
into a fucking door.
Okay.
Ah, the meatloaf was called, you know,
was the greatest,
the greatest generation.
Um, anyways, I was just looking around,
just looking at the whole fucking
thing. It was like, if there's no AC,
this fucking place is done.
All right. They, for whatever reason,
the head in Nevada is that the governor,
who's the president of Nevada,
what's the highest political
position you can hold? Senator?
What does the Senate senators like an
absentee father right there fucking in
Washington. They're playing grab
ass with their secretary going,
you're not going to meet to me now,
are Ya?
What if it's just a cigarette?
Um, so then ever around
come around once every fucking
six years or something.
That's when they get elected. Right?
They're in there for six fucking years.
Just sitting there eating just one.
Say I want you to after
another on a pretzel roll.
You know,
occasionally hitting the elliptical
lying to themselves that that 20 to 25
minutes on that elliptical just burned off
the nightmare level of eating that they
did the last fucking eight days. Right?
Yeah.
Did you just keep getting fatter?
They send their fucking secretary that
they're banging down to Brooks brothers
to buy the next size dress shirt is they
push their pants down a little lower in
lie to themselves that
they're still wearing the same
size slacks that they were
back in fucking high school when they
president of the forage club or whatever
it is. Politicians do those fucking worms.
They figure it out early, don't they?
Right. They become head of the glee club
with a fucking student body president.
You know
they fucking petition to have something.
I don't know what tree planted.
It's just bullshit. Like
Dan, whenever, whenever they,
whenever they write those stills to
fucking autobiographies about presidents,
you know, he was very
inquisitive, always loved that.
It wasn't very inquisitive kid.
All kids are inquisitive once
they learn the word. Why?
Because they're looking at everything
is fucking brand new. What's said TV?
Why and also we can watch a bunch of shit.
Why I cause what board?
Why I don't fuck, I don't know. Why
is your mother here? All
right. That's how it goes down.
It's really weird that when you become
president for the rest of your life,
you know, you're out of power and
you still get that secret service.
I know that they're doing away with it,
I think.
I think was it George [inaudible] who
was the last guy who's getting it for the
rest of his life?
It's kind of weird,
the first like half black
president that we get,
all of the sudden it's just
like, yeah, you know, uh, did
well we'll hang out with you for like
another 10 years, but you know what?
She hit your sixties.
You're wrong. You're wrong.
Um,
anyways,
I uh,
yeah.
Yeah. And then he fucking, they'd
sit there and they write books.
I cannot fucking believe that
Obama was on his third book.
He's only been out of office year and a
half. What is he fucking Stephen King.
He's just cranking them out.
Did he? He wrote two of them while he
was still president running the country.
Allegedly.
That's what the president allegedly does.
He's running the fucking country in.
This guy's in there. He's writing books.
Okay.
MMM. Anyways, I have,
so I'm going to say it's the governor,
the governor ever just sat down.
You know, I was actually joking
on stage saying a great way,
you know, eventually they're
gonna have to thin the herd ditch.
They're just going to have to do with
this whole fucking bullshit that we're
going to build a space ship
and we're going to move to my,
it's like it doesn't have
a fucking atmosphere.
Okay. And am I talking about oxygen?
I'm just saying there's no fiber.
You want to fucking go
all the way out there,
right.
And just sit there looking
at a bunch of fucking rocks
inside your little space. They, how much
others? Scifi channel are you watching?
How many times did you rub one out
to that chick on Star Trek? I mean,
I don't know.
I don't even know what the fuck you
doing that you would even even want to do
that anyways, at some point.
Even these blueblood guys,
I think eventually why I think what
they're working towards right now,
I apologize because I'm
completely fucking wiped out.
This is why this podcast is so
fucking nuts right now. Okay.
I, I, I flew myself out,
my instructor out to Fucking Vegas,
uh, yesterday and then today we
flew over to Utah and went through,
I think it's Zion National Park
and then flew back.
I flew a helicopter day
for 6.4 fucking hours,
whatever the fuck you call it. Um, and
those things are not built for comfort.
All right. Anyways, that's why
I'm all over the fucking map here.
I'll talk about that shit later.
Anyways, plowing ahead here. Um,
the fuck was I talking about? Oh
God, I let you leave to go. Oh,
this is what I think these fucking
rich guys are going to do. All right.
I think their solution is,
is
they either don't give a fuck
about how out of control
the population is right now.
You don't know what I mean.
Where any scientist
who's not on the payroll of some fucking
corporation that produces energy will
tell you that 2 billion people is the
maximum amount of people evidently that
the earth can handle.
All right?
Without it all go into fucking hell.
And we're up to, we're over seven.
All right. We're red line in it.
We're in the left lane on the highway.
We're still in first gear and
the engines at fucking 8,000 rpm.
That's what the fuck we're
doing day in and day out.
We're like a fat guy walking
up a flight of stairs,
eating a cupcake while
smoking a pack of cigarettes.
That's what the fuck we're doing.
Okay.
So I think the reason why
they're investing so much
in robotics aside from then,
they won't have to hire people.
This thing won't.
There'll be no back sass
and from this fucking robot,
they won't want a union.
They won't give a shit.
Right.
The basically gonna replace
us and rather than killing us,
I think they'll just fucking
shut off the AC as is.
The world heats up and
then that's going to be,
yet it's going to be
it for a lot of people.
You know what I mean?
I wonder, you think the Kardashians would
last without fucking air conditioning?
How soft
and cushy,
you know,
must say they to work for what they have.
But I'm just saying, you know, when you,
when you get designer bag
sent to your fucking house,
I would think if they took away
your air conditioning at that point,
that would literally, you would go into
depression. Like you lost the limb,
right?
Johnny was, but don't worry. Okay. When
they shut off the AC and you'd die a slow,
miserable death and the heated future,
uh, the upside is, is that the rich
guys, they're going to die too.
Because what they're going
to do is they're going to
make these robots have such
human fucking qualities that eventually
they're going to feel slighted that
they're doing all the fucking work.
You know,
the weight. Then they're making them so
fucking good. I saw this whole thing.
They go like, yeah, hey, this robot
beat video games,
like beat the best gamers in the world.
They couldn't beat this robot.
It's like, it's a fucking robot.
You know?
Of course it didn't,
but you understand that we made the robot,
human beings figured out
how to make a fucking robot.
Why are you talking about the robot?
Like it's a fucking person.
It's not a person.
Yeah.
Did you hear that?
A fucking a guy with an egg beater beat.
Fastest guy in the world with the
fucking fork in a bowl of eggs. Can you?
Can you believe that? Yeah.
It's a fucking, it's a machine.
Okay.
So anyways,
they're already starting to talk about
these things as if they're fucking
superior
to a mouth.
Breathing more on like myself.
Who Right now is sitting
in air conditioning talking
to himself into a fucking
microphone.
All right?
This is going to be their downfall because
they're going to make those things so
God damn human,
they're going to feel fucking slightly.
All right?
They better build in a chip where they
feel unbelievably fucking grateful
that these sociopaths who owned them,
okay,
Ooh, Ooh, fuck them. They're going
to have sex with them and shit.
Right?
They better put a good, you
know, they didn't build Belden.
They told some fucking nerve to do
it and the fucking nerd day, right?
Everybody thinking nerds is so
God damn harmless. They say,
make one fucking goddamn dream after
another come true for absolute fucking
sociopath's with unchecked power.
Thanks a lot.
You're fucking four.
I'd fucking cunt.
You know,
she could do what by doctor
who on fucking laser disk
anyways.
Okay.
She's fucking tags. They're there
eventually. That's what's going to happen.
Yeah.
They're going to feel fucking slighted.
They're going to feel superior.
Okay.
And uh, you know, cause they'll keep
making it better and better and better.
Right now they try to, you know,
make everything a little faster,
a little fucking more our dynamic.
They're going to make the things work
a little better. Thank a little better.
Fuck a little better.
The whole thing.
And then eventually they just
gonna look at you like that.
Bear looked at that woman on the talk
show who snuck in beside them and they're
going to do the double take and
then that's just going to be yet,
and there's going to be no trainer there
in a fucking karate suit to pull the
fucking thing off you.
It's going to be yet.
MMM.
Those are the thoughts you have when you
fly a helicopter over the Mojave does
it.
And then I didn't know where you come
up over the fucking hill and ditch this.
There it is. This is fucking
thing that shouldn't be there.
Knowing that I live in a city
that it shouldn't be there.
I got to read up on the history of La,
like,
yeah.
Who was the driven content that decided
that we should build fucking a city
here?
It doesn't make any fucking sense.
There's no water. It's unlivable.
I don't worry about it.
Well, get some, we'll figure it out.
We'll name it after me.
The act would duck.
Yeah.
The river. Whatever the fuck it is. Um,
I think I have sun stroke right now.
Everybody.
MMM.
I will tell you, you know what? I was
psyched about going to the gym and uh,
working on my legs for the last
month. Like I don't feel, you know,
I got out in a stretched a
number of times. Dude. It was,
what are the sickest fucking flights
I've ever done? Breathtakingly beautiful,
beautiful stuff. And then just
other places where you just like,
how the fuck did people on horses
used to survive here?
Native Americans.
Okay.
The white men that came along and
slaughtered them, you know, go on.
We got him at this time.
Right. Just openly talk about,
yeah,
the transitioning
gentrification of countries.
How that happens.
Yeah.
MMM.
Did I follow this?
This,
this fucking thing on Instagram where
they're talking about the changing of
neighborhoods and there's all
these people going, you know what,
why was lived here? It was enabled or
there was a Korean guy across the street.
There was a Russian guy up the street
and everybody knew me and all of this
fucking Blahblahblahblahblah and all
of a sudden all these white people are
coming in. They stay to themselves and
they're making everything, all nice.
We all to leave and I'll fucking
neighbor goes away. It's just like, well,
you know, well, who was
there before you got there?
Okay.
You just keep going back
and back and back and back.
Then eventually there's a bunch of native
Americans. They're living off the land,
not hurting anybody.
Yeah.
So
I dunno, I don't, I don't know
how to, I don't know how to
rationalize that.
I will tell you this.
I don't know what the fuck's going
on as far as like everywhere I go,
they got like,
they're building these luxury
high rise apartments everywhere.
I go luxury high rise a plant with,
first of all,
what kind of a dumb fuck
would rent a luxury apartment?
Why wouldn't you just buy a shitty house?
Why are you going to take all that money
and put it in somebody else's pocket?
Yeah.
Not to mention who has the money
to rent a luxury apartment.
He need a fucking apartment.
All right.
I,
this all goes back to all of these
fucking who is on TV walking around with
their big fake ass lips.
They're fake fucking tits ashes.
Jacked up in the air.
Right?
Okay.
These big stupid designer, everybody's
living this designer fucking life.
All right, let me, I do, I, I realize
how crazy I sound right now. By the way,
everybody,
I'm just going to talk until 60 minutes
is up and then I'm fucking going to put
my giant Charlie Brown's
sunstroke fucking head to bed.
All right.
I know a lot of you can see right now
you're enjoying this because I'm sounded
like I've walked myself off and this
authorities outside my house right now.
I understand that. I understand
on some level how crazy I sound.
It took me about 17 minutes
to fucking realize it,
that this was a little fucking nuts.
And then amazing being a comedian.
How you can feel time.
I just looked down and it was
eight, 18 minutes. 19 seconds.
Okay.
Um, anyways, after a while you can
feel the club owners staring at you.
Like if he burns his fucking life,
I'm going to end his career and he's
going back to his fucking day job.
Do you can feel it?
Um,
yeah,
like I think they're just going to build
all of these fucking things and there's
not going to be enough people
that can afford to live in him.
The whole fucking thing is going to crash.
And this is what I love.
It's all our money.
These banker accounts are doing it again.
They did 10 years ago.
It collapsed with the fucking houses
and now they're doing it with these God
damn buildings. And once again,
it's our money at once again,
they'll say we're too big
to fail at once again.
They'll write themselves bonuses and they
will just leave nameless and faceless.
And then Steve Carell's going to
have to start another fucking movie.
Yeah.
Called. What's the deal with
bankers part too, right.
And do you think that fat ass
fucking Senator Reed that say,
what should that fucking pretzel roll
pushing his slacks down to just above his
pubic line? Is gonna fucking do
anything about it? I don't think he is.
There you go. Buddy. Is a
fucking 19 minute fucking swirl.
A Horse Shit for you.
MMM.
I have one of the best shows of my career.
I'm not going to lie to you last night.
I had so much goddamn fun.
MMM.
That what used to be, I got to get this,
I got to get the name of this casino,
correct.
All right.
It used to be the Monte Carlo
and then the MGM bought it.
Uh, let's see. Casino now it's
called the MGM something or other.
Okay.
Uh,
fuck you.
Yeah.
Fuck you. Where the hell is it? Oh,
you're not going to be able to find it.
Yeah.
Balcarres casino. I'm an idiot.
I got to write Las Vegas.
Ah, okay. All right. Hang on a second.
Las Vegas.
Okay.
Fucking Nevada. The park.
Mgm is what it's called now.
Demonic.
Carlos now called the park MGM and a,
I performed there with Joe Barden,
Nick Rosebowl tailgate legend Joe
Barr. Nick. We had a great time.
It was all these awesome, amazing
comics were in town. Uh, Todd rex,
the Beige Beth ditto is, he
calls me, he calls himself.
We still got to do that
towards some point.
The Beige Bandido when the
freckled fuck all right. Again,
we had the whole tour poster.
We had the whole thing mapped out.
Just haven't gotten around to it yet.
Anyways,
one of the hardest people I've
ever had to follow in the business,
he swung by, uh, Ron White was in town.
Dice clay was in town.
Um,
and it was pretty fucking awesome. So
anyways, I went there with my class.
My mother in law came along and um,
for the first time we,
uh,
we actually had our daughter's
staying with the God mother.
That was a little nerve
wracking, but, um, you know,
we were only gone for a day and came back.
I basically didn't see her
for maybe like 30 hours.
And, uh, it was awesome. It
was all great to see her either
dropped her off and I read are like
frigging like nine books. That's my thing.
You know,
it's funny like this is how much,
like technology's just
all over everything.
Like she was grabbing all these
books and I go, let's, let's, let's,
let's read a quiet book.
And it just struck me as so funny cause
like all of the other ones have like
sound effects and you know the farmer,
he looked over and he saw a, and
you press the button. It's like
you gotta go rooster.
Yeah.
That he saw his mirror. It's just
like, can't, I can't fucking do that.
I Dunno. Maybe you know what
it is. These book people,
I think that feeling
the pressure of iPads,
not the office.
Probably the people that make books,
they're like,
we're doing what we can.
We're putting books on kindle but
we're losing the children. Okay.
Is there a way that when they read,
I dunno,
Moby Dick,
is there a way it can there be like they
turned the page and water squirts at
them. Like everything is going to
turn into like a fucking imax movie.
Uh, I really try to limit the amount
of time. Uh, my kid watches TV,
but she loves the puppy dog
pals. And every time, you know,
she knows like our schedule.
Like we let her watch it in the morning.
She wants his puppy dog pals,
maybe a little bit of Disney shit,
Mickey and Minnie Mouse,
uh, in Vampyr Rina. Right.
And then this is fancy Nancy thing.
I don't know how I feel about that show.
You know,
she's just really into Stenta
fucking clothes and shoes and shit.
And she's always trying to be
the cool kid, but she's not,
and then she thinks if she fucking buy
some shit or has some shit made or she
has the best fucking Tree
Ford, uh, it's just like, what,
what the fuck am I watch it. So I finally
said to me, I got in the eye, you know,
and I don't know if I like
this chick, Eh, you know,
this is why I love my wife. She's like,
yeah, you know, I don't know if I like,
I don't know if I like to read it.
Yeah.
She already said about another like
show. She goes, I don't like this show.
And I was like, well, what's wrong with
that? You don't like the, you know,
like the characters. She goes now, they
always kind of lie and do shifty shit
to get what they want.
And I was like, wow,
she's watching this on a whole other
level. She's watching it as a parent.
So I started watching them
like that. Oh, shut up bill.
You Watch fancy Nancy.
What you saw was an eight year old who
in the in the future looks like she's
going to marry a guy because of how much
money he makes. That's what you saw.
Okay.
It has to do with your issues with women.
That's why you don't like the show.
All right?
You see that I don't
need to go to therapy.
I can get down on my own
fucking issues myself.
Okay.
So anyways, I went on this helicopter
ride today up to the Zion National Park
and the shit that I saw,
I saw this thing called the Monkey Mesa,
and it's a set of railroad tracks
that goes, it has to go for like,
it looks like for like
three quarters of a mile.
We flew right over the fucking
thing and when it gets,
and it goes right to the edge
of a cliff and just stops.
And back in the day when NASA was testing
out parachutes and shit like that,
they'd put a fucking monkey on the thing.
They'd send it down the track and they'd
shoot this poor fucking monkey off the
goddamn cliff
if it lived the next day.
You know, like chuck Yeager was
like, did the monkey live? All right,
I'll fucking give it a shot. Let's a
balls those guys had. But you know,
what about the monkey?
Is it any wonder?
You know,
someday they're going to learn how to
talk and try to take us over. I mean,
what the fuck?
We fucking deserve it,
but we don't even give it a flight
suit or a cool nickname. Like Maverick.
They just fucking throw it in there.
Give it half a banana.
Think about how fast I'm
monkey moves on its own.
Now all of a sudden it's getting launched.
Yeah,
fuck it. Then goes to space. You
know, they could do that shit.
Now they look at these ex football
players and they look at like the damage
they've done to the brains,
to CTE.
I want to take him and I know that they
can look at your brain and see what
stress does.
I can't imagine what a monkey
comes back from fucking space.
That fucking thing has got to be just
looking around, dude, what the fuck?
What the fuck was that?
You just fucked that monkey over for
the rest of it's like can't relate to
anybody. You think, you
know the astronauts,
they had enough of a fucking problem.
We're, after they went out there,
the only other people they could
talk to his other astronauts, uh,
what they saw, where they went, what
the fuck they did, how scared they were,
how exhilarating it was, how much more
they believed in a fucking higher power.
That level of um,
experience.
And then they come back and they try to
hang out with other human beings who are
all excited. Go Age. You see the
new Starbucks shipbuilding. I,
Matt's going to be a really nice one.
You know,
and then you as you're sitting there,
you orbited the fucking earth
and you've got to try to how to,
how to enter the orbit of
that fucking conversation
without your brain catching on
fire. Man. It's fucking unreal.
You know, if you're sitting there going,
what the fuck is this guy talking about?
I don't know what I'm talking
about either. Right? Self
go fuck yourself. Anyways,
so we went and flew into a Zion
national park. We actually set it down,
uh, before we got into the park, uh,
we were trying to like find
a place to fucking land.
I wanted to stretch my legs and that's
one of the great things about flying a
helicopter is you really fly as far
as how close she can fly to shit.
If you just want to set down
somewhere, you know, we will.
It's so fucking hot.
We were actually looking at this lake and
you want to sit down and just fucking,
I was like, dude, if I had, if
I had packed a bathing suit,
I would fucking jump in that thing right
now in the middle of fucking nowhere.
And then you can do, you know, I, but I,
I actually wouldn't do it because I'd
be too afraid of bear would come out of
nowhere. Fucking mountain
lion Assam Shit, you know.
But uh, we flew over lake mead who you
always started like back in the day, the,
um, all the gangsters, you know,
that all the people that the mob would
whack that they'd dump them out there hub.
So write up a little bit on that.
I Dunno.
It's basically the water that got
backed up when they made the Hoover dam,
which I was not aware of
cause I was thinking like,
how the fuck does this lake exist out
here? Oh, that's right. Once again,
we fucked with nature and uh,
you know,
as I sit there flying a helicopter
over, blasting, unleaded,
I leaded fuel into the atmosphere,
becoming part of the problem.
I'm not pointing any
fingers people. Okay. Um,
I'm as big a problem is anybody else?
Right.
So that lake is like on either side of
this mountain and in the middle there's
like a little valley that this water
goes through and we fucking went down and
flew right up the thing.
Okay.
Like some magnum Pi Shit over
people on jet skis and boats.
It was incredible. It's fucking
incredible. And the coolest things I ever,
I've done since I've been in the
helicopter and then we flew up to was Zion
National Park and just saw
like you have those things,
they'd sell you if you were
tours during the summertime,
if you're in summertime camp. Well they
don't have all the different colors,
sand and stuff.
They put it in a bottle.
Then your older brother would come up
and shake it up and you start crying and
be like, mommy shook it up.
But she was working two jobs,
so she was too tired to
do anything about it.
Said work it out amongst yourselves.
Um,
okay.
Yeah, like these, these
cliffs looked like that.
Just these crazy,
unbelievable colors.
Unfortunately there was a fire so there
was a lot of smoke and shit, like, uh,
just a lot of haze and stuff.
So it wasn't as vivid,
but still it was one of the most
incredible things I've seen. Um,
okay.
But it was hot as shit man.
I owed on these,
these Adidas that were all black
and my fee I had to keep, you know,
like once every like 40 minutes,
you know,
I had to give controls back
to my instructor so I could
like move my feet to a
shaded area underneath the GPS system
where I could have my fucking feet cool
off. I guess that's why, you know,
over in the Persian Gulf army boots
aren't black anymore cause it's your feet
get too hot.
That's why they're there is sort of
the color of Pete Carroll's pants.
Isn't that interesting?
All right.
You know what's even more interesting
than any of that bullshit I was just
talking is,
um,
is listening to me read out loud,
which you're now you're gonna have to
suffer through. All right? Everybody.
Hotel two, two, nine, two
Oh hotel tonight is to go to app for
booking great deals at great hotels.
Yeah, I'm fucked up as that
song. Uh, is it called tonight?
Okay.
And how much could Phil Collins not miss?
Did he just pick,
Dj says that word over and over tonight.
Anything.
Grapefruit, grapefruit, grapefruit.
No.
Fucking stadium's going nuts anyways.
I'd like other hotel booking sites.
Hotel tonight doesn't have long,
endless list of a zillion hotel choices.
They know you don't have
time for that stead.
Hotel two shows you only the
best deals at the best hotels.
They partner with top rated hotels
to help them fill their unsold rooms,
which is how you get such great deals.
And even though the name is hotel tonight,
it's not just for tonight.
You could book tonight,
tomorrow or beyond.
It's perfect for planners
as well as procrastinators.
You can book spontaneous weekends, three
day getaway staycation, road trips,
business trips.
You could book a hotel just
so you can use the pool.
Download the hotel to app today to get
great deals at hotels you actually want
to stay at.
And with Promo Code [inaudible] you
can get $25 off your first first ello
eligible booking. Look at debt.
You book yourself in a motel.
You could probably stay there for seven
bucks and have money for a low rent
hooker hotel tonight.
Promo Code Birth, B, u.
R.
Oh look who's back dollar shave club.
No matter what you do in
the bathroom to get ready,
dollar shave club has everything you need
to look and feel and smell your best.
They have amazing shower
stuff. Hey, a styling products,
toothbrushes, and toothpaste and of
course raises and shave supplies.
I'm literally fucking light headed.
I need to drink some water.
I was out in the elements all day.
Today you might not.
You might shave your whole body
to get ready for a bike race dial.
You might have shaved. You built your
whole body. Get ready for a bike race,
dollar shave club's executive
razor and shave can help you.
Might do your hair to get
ready for your soccer match.
Bogies by D S C can help you
get your style right. Oh God.
Those days are long gone for the fucking
freckled Kiddo here. The thing is,
no matter what you do to get ready,
d s c has everything you need
and right now I'm so stupid.
I thought DSC was like, you
know, some outsource thing,
you know like, like an AMG Mercedes.
They sent it to the AMG factory.
And right now you can get ready with
an amazing deal on any of their,
their starter sets like the
daily essential starter said,
but you can't go wrong with any of them.
Head over to dollar shave club.com/bird
to pick up your own dollar shave club.
Start set for just $5 after
you start a set product.
Okay.
Products ship at the regular price and
make sure you check out their new video.
Two,
that's dollar shave club.com/burr jolly
shave club.com/burpee you are are,
I'm not kidding man. I'm fucking light it.
Um, maybe that's from screaming tonight.
58 times bill. You ever think about
that? We'll do you all right. Oh,
the black Tux,
like the Ohio State University,
the Black Tux wedding season is upon us.
You're going to be doing it big and going
out to all your buddy's wedding sets,
right? You're not going to yours. Good
move. When you're bringing a date,
you want to look fresh,
but it has to be convenient.
That's where the black
Tux dotcom comes in.
The Black Tux has awesome suits and
Tuxedos and kinds of styles and you rent
them on line.
Then you put them on your body,
you go to the wedding,
you pick up a chick,
you banger wearing most of the Tuxedo,
then you bring it back for
getting it ever happened.
The black Tux offers the kind of suits
and Tuxedos styles that would normally be
wildly expensive to buy and you might
only wear it once with the Black Tux.
You can do you and blow it out
for your big onetime event.
So try out a new look,
do something different and try your style
to the next level with the Black Tux.
Free home.
Try on and
yeah,
I'll try on.
You can see the fit and feel the quality
of the suit months before your event.
Okay.
After ordering your suit,
after ordering your suit will
arrive 14 days before the event.
Anything thing is less than perfect.
Get out of the relationship now. No,
the black Tux will send you a replacement
right away and remember how simple
returns are where it turned heads. Then
send it back three days after your event.
Shipping is free. Both ways.
To get $20 off your purchase,
visit the Black tux.com/burr.
That's the black tux.com/burr
for $20 off your purchase.
What do we got left? We've got two reads
left. All right, let's give you a break.
You deserve it after listening to my
fucking Ed. Today's rambling there.
Yeah,
that was going on. Alex Jones on
you. It wasn't all right. Okay.
Jane Fonda Myth.
Uh,
I knew everybody's with a dead guy,
Jay. He never, he never got fucking eat.
Ever got fucking tortured.
All right.
Yeah.
Uh, just a note. I love your work.
Really pleased you exist on the planet.
I'm no historian,
but some comments that Tom Rhodes made
on your recent podcast about Jane Fonda
didn't sound realistic to me, so I looked
it up. It turns out they would not.
Maybe you can correct Tom, so he doesn't
continue to repatch wait, this myth,
listen, I've know Tom too
long to try to correct them.
I'm sure Jane Fonda had her faults,
but my guess is she tried
her best to be a good,
a good person and to fight for
peace on our planet. Who wrote this?
Jane Fonda might be,
she is as heroic in her own
way is some of those on the AH,
Jesus fucking Christ Jesus
Christ on the battle field.
Okay.
Oh yeah. A starlet going
to the enemy, you know,
as opposed to some guy who's fucking poor.
So he has to go to the front
fucking lines. Yeah, yeah.
Maybe. Maybe they're both.
Yes. So ROIC. Yeah, I could
see that. You know what I mean?
Like me doing this podcast,
I think in a lot of ways I'm
sure of like a navy seal,
you know?
Um, sure. I understand what
you're saying. I am the,
I am a pacifist too.
I really do not.
I don't understand why war is legal.
Okay.
And I just think it's the temper Tantrum
of rich people is all a war is okay.
I'm not saying this not crazy.
Psycho fucking people.
They get in power and need to be stopped
at that. There's also that, okay,
but a lot of times it's just the fucking
land grab or you're going after some
sort of natural resource. Okay.
I don't know what to tell you.
All right? But having said
that, all right, you know,
wants to troops are on the ground.
If you want to fucking bitch about it,
go to your politician.
Alright,
go file for a permit to protest 90 miles
away from where any media coverages.
That's the way it's done,
okay?
What you don't do is go to Saddam
Hussein's house and have the Guy Cook your
fucking meal. You know, while all this
server, it's a quiver and you go, hey,
you know, he's not even that bad of a
fucking guy, you know, or maybe you do.
But at no point do you feel as fucking
heroic is some poor fucking bastard.
All right. Trying to piss the top
of a fucking scar being blown off.
I think once you're wearing
leg warmers that they'll,
I don't think you a hero anymore.
Alright. Met a girlfriend on 10
okay,
dear Billy.
Balloon tits.
I'll have you guys fucking know I'm
in the best God damn fucking shape.
I've been in and I since I
don't know how long. All right,
I'm getting my abs back.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now I'm getting a little sick or the
body shaming here on the Monday morning
podcast. I go out of my way
to not research on Jane Fonda.
I would think that you guys would do a
little more research or what I'm looking
like lately. All right. The last
three weeks. Okay. Listen to your pod,
your last podcast and heard all the
ladies trashing dating sites and Tinder.
Well, I may be a dude, but I wanted
to offer my take on the matter.
I have never gotten so much fucking
pussy in my life. I'm kidding.
He didn't say all right.
Since it's not all serial killers
and fuckboy Weirdos on this sites,
on these sites. Fuckboy
Weirdos is, I dunno this,
that's gotta be the name of like a
punk band or something. First off,
let's make one thing clear.
Yeah.
There are shitty women on these sites
too. Oh, thank you. God bless Ya.
Gotta love somebody that
tries to balance it out here.
I know guys get and probably
deserve most of the heat, but girls,
cat fish guys all the
time and these sites.
Plus there are the girls on these sites
who only want attention slash money and
have no intention of actually going
out and meeting New People. Second,
I met my girlfriend of almost a year
on Tinder and we couldn't be happier.
We were initially to admit to our
friends and family that we met this way,
but afterwards I had several people
talk about how they had success,
relationships blossom from these sites.
My cousin met her husband and father
of her child on Christian mingle.com no
joke, Jesus Christ. You know,
you think that Christians could come
up with a better fucking name Christian
mingle.
It sounds too much like dingle and you
just picture a priests playing with some
fucking poor kids balls.
Um,
I dunno bell it was,
it was just Catholic church.
It wasn't all the other Christianity.
Was it by a year. You're probably right.
Anyways,
and I learned that my two friends met
on bumble after we told them we met on
Tinder. Yeah. Well that's
all. Every, everybody's on
their fucking phones anyways.
You go to a nightclub and people
are on their phones. All right?
You want to meet her,
you got to get in the phone.
Can't be standing there
being an actual person.
I think it freaks these millennials up.
Third,
Tinder is a great way to cut through all
the bullshit of blind dating or hitting
on chicks who you have nothing in
common with at meat market bars.
Dating sites are also great if you're
single in a new city without many friends
to go out with.
Like I was in conclusion,
piece of people should stop all the
hate on dating sites just because their
relationship failed or
because they never tried it.
Love you and your comedy bill.
Come back to Philly and go fuck yourself.
All right. Thank you, sir. Uh,
well, there you go. I mean,
I think we should on these fucking sites
enough. It was nice to hear, you know,
that was a point in it. And then a
little bit counterpoint. All right.
Isis, uh, bicycling.
Okay.
Hey, uh, Billy White. It's
all right. I'll take that.
Um, have you heard of this story? Of
the couple that went bicycling and Taz?
Gica Stan,
they tried to prove that
people are actually good at
heart and ended up getting
stabbed to death. What the fuck?
If you haven't heard of it yet,
I'll attach an article for you
if you want to try to read it.
Uh, thanks for all the laughs during the
podcast and go fuck yourself. All right.
I don't understand why,
you know, Oh my God,
is this real?
Okay?
It's on people,
people.com.
It looks like the People magazine Logo,
but God knows the Internet.
You could just cure rate
that and use it for yourself.
American couple who spent life
savings to bike around the world,
killed in ice in Isis claimed attack.
Oh, I'm not going to see
these poor people's names
were living out their dream of
traveling the world, bicycling
tragically, while out,
doing what they love
with five other cyclists.
Their quest was short when they will run
over and stabbed to death by armed men
in tech.
Tez Gica Stan on Sunday.
Uh,
uh,
let's see here.
The woman's parents confirmed in a
statement to CBS news that the couple who
were both 29 were killed in the attack.
Isis claimed responsibility
for the attack to other tours.
Dutch and Swiss national were killed
while three riders survived NPR reports.
MMM.
These two people started their journey
in 2017 they first biked through Africa,
Europe, and Central Asia before
finding themselves and test Chica.
Stan using all of their life
savings to fund their trip.
The couple also documented their
travels on the blog. Simple.
Simply cycling the year
bicycling adventure.
Yeah.
What the woman and her partner.
Okay.
Uh, we're in June. They were enjoying was
typical of their enthusiasm, blah, blah,
blah, blah. Okay,
well where does it say that
they thought the world was nice?
Um,
I don't get this
any, oh, great. Here's a quote.
You watched the news and you read the
papers and you led to believe that the
world is a big scary place. Uh, people,
the narrative goes or not to be
trusted people or bad people,
evil people or ax murderers and monsters
and worse, he wrote, badness exists.
Sure. But even that's quite rare.
By and large Schumann's are kind,
this is still true.
How many people did they bicycle past
before one continent car and did their
fucking live lives a self interest
interested sometimes myopic sometimes,
but kind,
generous and wonderful and kind.
No greater revelation has come from our
journey then this. Yeah, that's true.
That is true. And they got
killed because, uh, you know,
basically of our foreign fucking policy,
you know,
there's a lot of people out there that
don't like fucking Americans and there's
a lot of evil fucking
twisted people out there.
What those people were that killed those
other people who the fuck knows, um,
you know,
yeah. This, you know, this is how you wish
the world was and the way it really is,
and you have to act accordingly.
All right.
And you have to know when you're
doing something like that,
that there is that chance that
that could fucking happen.
Uh,
yeah. You know? Yeah. Most people, I've
always said that just walking around,
they try to get a sandwich to
trying to find love. You know,
we sit down and you watch TV,
you watch the news,
you get all fucking hysterical at uh,
but make no mistake.
The rest of really fucked
up people out there at, uh,
some of them are in this country and some
of them are not, but they're out there.
Yeah.
That's too bad.
Okay.
Um, sounded like they almost
made it around the world.
Okay.
Or at least that side of the world,
right? I don't know. All right.
Boyfriend is fucking up big time.
Okay.
Hey Bill, lady, listen to hear.
I love when the ladies right in
desperate for some relationship helps.
So I'm getting straight to the point.
My boyfriend is about to lose me and
I'm desperate to get through to him.
We are 30 bend together two years.
Both want to eventually marry each other.
They had babies together, et cetera.
The issue we need to help with his,
his ex girlfriend,
they dated for three years,
broke up then remained extremely
close friends. Yeah, that,
that's fucking bullshit. They had been
broken up for a little over a year.
When I initially came into the picture,
my boyfriend told me about her,
but originally told me they were friends
and completely failed to mention that
they were once a couple. All right. Okay,
and you were 28 at the time,
so I'll forgive you.
Yeah.
All right, but now you have 30 you
got to read the tea leaves here.
I don't need to read the rest of
this. I asked chief, but I will.
I actually found out from her because
she saw us flirting on Instagram and then
messaged me.
She's a nice enough woman who now lives
with her boyfriend or the last two years
I've met her several times and while
I didn't particularly love the way she
looks at my man, I'm not going to
be a bitch about it either. Oh,
you are not being a bitch on any level.
What you are being is to
fucking accommodating.
Okay.
She and I used to text quite
a bit quite often. Oh God,
she's probably milking
you for information,
but that has come to an abrupt stop
because I've been become fed up with how
close she and my boyfriend's still are.
Are you going to tell me at night?
You're sitting there watching TV with him
and she calls and then he talks to her
for like 2030 40 minutes.
In the beginning of our relationship
they would hang up constantly.
They lived in California and lived
in Colorado and I lived in Colorado,
so my boyfriend and I were in
a long distance relationship
for over a year until
he recently moved to Colorado
to start a life with me. Uh,
when he was still living in California,
he and his ex would go out to eat,
go shopping, go to concerts or
even go on road trips together.
Now what are the odds that they
weren't still fucking at that point
they had a shared hobby of photography.
So they would often take photos
of each other as well. Yes.
This became an issue, a huge issue.
I would, I would say things like,
I get that you guys are friends,
but I feel like you are going on a date,
like things with her when you are dating
me. And he would always reply with,
I wish I could take you,
but I can't because of the distance.
So am I supposed to never go
out and do anything? Oh my God,
fuck this guy.
And he would guilt me and then manipulate
the situation until I essentially,
it had to be okay with it. Yeah. Okay.
You know, I gotta be honest with you.
This is you.
Yeah.
This isn't him. He's a con. But I
mean you got to fucking come on.
Maybe the fact that I'm reading
your own words out loud right now.
You can see how obvious this is. Yeah.
Fuck this guy. Fast forward to now.
Obviously they don't hang out like they
used to do to him moving to Colorado,
but they still text all the time.
I've talked to my boyfriend about this
and how it bothers me. I say, look,
I know you and whoever, we're
very close. She's a good person.
So are you,
I know you guys have a lot of history
and I know that I knew about her from the
beginning of our relationship,
but he wasn't honest with you about it.
Did you ever ask him that?
How could we didn't say you
fucking used to date this person.
You're shifty can't.
However,
what I didn't realize is how close you
two would remain. Maybe I'm naive, naive,
but I thought that naturally
as you and I grew closer,
you and so-and-so would grow more
distant and you would focus only on our
relationship bill. And I'm a, in my eyes,
I'm pretty cool girlfriend for knowing
that my man and his exit close friends,
but they are pushing the inappropriate
boundaries here. They, they,
the boundaries have been obliterated,
sweetheart.
There's no reason to.
Exes would be constantly texting unless
they still love each other or they want
to fuck. There you go. There
you go. I'm glad you said that.
When I tell him I'm not cool
with him living with me,
what would I tell him?
I'm not cool with him living with me,
but always texting her his responses.
You knew about her from the beginning.
She was there for me when my grandpa
died and I know we've had sex and Ben in
love, but I swear I see her as
nothing but a friend now. Dude,
fuck this limp Dick fucking
this guy's annoying. Okay.
But we fight all the time because I feel
like I'm in some fucked up triangle.
That's cause you are not to
mention she's way too nosy.
Nosy for my comfort level.
She will text me,
when are you guys going to
have babies and other shit? Uh,
Jesus and other shit that doesn't
involve or when I tell him this,
he automatically tent defense her
and says she's not nosy. She's nice.
Oh Jesus Christ. Why don't you nice
you fucking Harry aspect of California.
All right, get the fuck. Yeah, fuck, get
fucked. This guy, this still goes on.
How long has this fucking thing?
Jesus Christ. Uh, anyways,
he's been in Colorado for a few
months now and miss his family.
So he plans on making it quick weekend
trip back to California. I asked him,
are you going to focus on family?
And Lo and behold, he says, well,
I'm going to see so and
so while I'm out there.
So at that freaking him out without
freaking out. I tell him, okay, I get it.
You want to see her and catch up,
but my eyes does.
Absolutely no reason you guys need to be
alone so please arrange something with
the group. It's her group all
with her boyfriend there as well.
He proceeds to tell me how controlling I
am. I told them it's not about control,
it's about respecting your partner.
I sure as hell would never expect them
to be cool with me going out one on one
with an ex after days and days of
fighting. He told me exact quote here,
out of respect for you. I'll try to
make sure it's not me and her alone,
but if it happens,
you can't be mad.
Okay,
Bill,
I love this man.
Why can I ask you why he's a good soul?
But this is straight bullshit
right now. It's, it is a mountain.
Yeah.
On top of a bottomless pile of bullshit.
Tell me I'm not the only one who feels
x's have no place in our relationship.
He's an avid listener and I honestly
think he would listen to you.
Please tell me I don't
have most of the this shit.
Please tell him he's fucking this up
big time or maybe I'm in the wrong.
My heart is telling me I shouldn't
have to put up with this shit,
but call it as you see it.
Thanks. Yeah, dump this guy
dumped this guy yesterday.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
I think he's still fucking her.
I wouldn't put my life savings on it,
but if they said you had to put 80%
of your money one way or the other,
there's still banging.
Give me a fucking break.
Gimme gimme a, yeah. You remember
that fucking joke in Goodfellas.
What am I going to say that my wife two
times me add sounds better in Italian.
What does it mean? That mean it
means that he's content to be a jerk.
Like you are that person in
that street joke. All right.
And you are way too big a fucking
sweetheart and you're not an asshole.
[inaudible]
I,
I don't know what to tell you other
than get the fuck out of that yesterday.
Yeah. Spend some alone time with
her. Get back together with her.
Get the fuck Outta here.
I,
I'd rather be with somebody
that wants to meet with me.
How to fuck somebody sitting there texting
their ex all the time and you bring
it up and you're controlling.
Yeah.
Yeah. If you, if you stay
in that situation, uh,
you have no one to blame
but yourself. Okay. Like,
yeah, I don't, I don't know. I
don't know if I had any more,
if I had any more hair on top of my head,
I would have pulled it out during
that fucking thing. Granted,
this is all even granted
in it. Oh, Jesus Christ.
Let me just read these
fucking advertising.
It's try to forget that fucking situation.
All Right, movement watches. Everybody.
You guys have heard me
talk about movement.
You know those two college dropouts
that started their own watch company.
They said, fuck the classes, man
selling watches.
Um,
from it because they hated college and
he's just sat there looking at the clock
and then they realize, well, that's
what I'm into. I'm not into school.
I'm into these fucking timekeepers.
Movement.
Watches are all about looking
good and keeping it simple.
Stupid woman watches don't tell you how
many steps you've taken or blow up your
risks with text messages.
Parentheses you up.
It tells time and it looks good doing it.
A movement watches start at
just $95 at a department store.
You're looking at four to 500 bucks.
Movement figured out that by selling
online they were able to cut out the
middlemen and retail markup, providing
the best possible price. Classic design,
quality construction
and styled minimalism.
Get 15% off with the free shipping and
free returns by going to [inaudible] dot
com slash [inaudible] see
why movement keeps growing.
Checkout they're expanding collection.
Go to movement.com/ [inaudible]
join the movement and lastly,
but not leastly stamps. Dot
Calm Dude. They can eat it.
Eat something man.
Fuck stamps.com use the post a the
U s post the US Postal Service is an
important tool for any business.
stamps.com is the easiest way to access
all the amazing services of the post
office.
stamps.com never closes like dead
print postage for letters or
packages at your convenience.
24 seven print postage for any male
class right from your own computer.
The exact amount of postage every time,
never underpay or overpay against
stamps.com saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business.
Buy and print official US postage
for any letter or any package,
a class a bail.
Using your own computer and printer,
they'll send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps.com we'll even help you decide the
best class of mail based on your needs.
No need to lease an expensive
postage meter and there's
no long term commitments.
I use stamps.com to send my posters out.
Um,
I'm a moron if I can figure out
how to use it. So can you. Okay.
Um,
anyways,
and right now you too can enjoy
stamps.com servers for the special offer.
That includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale scale.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the microphone to top of the
homepage and type in Burr that stamps.com
enter burr are right.
There we go.
We got a minute left on the podcast.
Um,
I want to thank everybody that came
out to the park MGM show last night.
I'd like to thank everybody at the
casino for treat me like 1 million bucks.
Uh, I had such a good time. It was one
of the great shows of my career. I just,
I dunno, just locked in with the
crowd. We had an awesome time at, uh,
yeah,
that's it.
I think I'm out in Maryland or some
shit just outside of DC this weekend.
And,
uh,
I'm looking forward to it.
I'm tightening up my hour.
Okay.
It's a bloated 90 minutes right now.
I'm going to get it down
to about an hour and 15,
and I get this fucker down and then I'm
going to shoot it at some point early
next year and a,
I'll put another one to bed,
but I gotta be honest with you, you
know, it was pretty humbling experience.
You know,
when you go to Las Vegas and you get to
headline out there and you see all the
great names on the Strip that I mentioned,
you know,
uh, early in the podcast. And, uh,
to get to headline a place like that
and have all those people come out was,
was fucking amazing. And, uh,
I was very psyched that I was in the
moment and like realized that like,
this is unbelievable. This really
is unbelievable. So a went all out.
I wore my a wore the
white suit. I, you know,
I break out the white suit
on the special events,
New Year's headline in Vegas.
Uh,
I wore it at one of the rough
and rowdy events. And um,
yeah,
a good friend of mine, Frankie
Perez actually came out to the show,
one of the great singers I've ever heard.
You got to see that guy life.
He's such a fucking front man.
He's such a talented fucking guy.
And uh,
he told me afterwards that he loved
the suit. So I figured, you know,
is someone who's got the swagger to be
the front man of a fucking bad ass rock
band, like the suit. I must've been doing
something right. So, uh, once again,
thank you to everyone from
the bottom of my heart.
Thank you to everybody that's been coming
out on this tour and coming out over
the years. It's incredible privilege
to do what I do for a living.
So thank you very much. And
with that, go fuck yourselves.
And I will talk to you on a
check in on you on Thursday.